there is a great headline from the new
york post today
after news came out that the co-founder
of blm patrice cullors
has been spending millions and millions
of dollars on houses
buying up beautiful homes the headline
in the new york post is
black lives manners or the other one is
by
large mansions that's the other new
meaning of blm
patrice cullers is a
leftist activist that is her career
that's what she's done
she did not start some business other
than blm i guess that is
a pretty pretty effective corporation in
america
she did not invent some cool gizmo she
didn't work in finance for a long time
she's made all of her money on race
hustling
and radical marxist activism
her words not mine she has admitted this
on on
air she's a trained marxist she
then readdressed this when that old
video came to light and she said yeah i
like i like marxist activism yeah that's
what we're doing
this is the topic by the way of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available now for pre-order
thank you to everybody who has
pre-ordered it we have
some great stuff we're gonna be doing
the audio book soon you can order a
first edition autographed copy of that
at premiere collectibles
the the topic of that book is how we
went from
some obscure brilliant actually
left-wing theorists
about a hundred years ago up to blm
today what that through line is what
political correctness is what woke-ism
is what cancel culture is
so patrice cullers might be facing a
little bit of a cancel culture on her
own because now it's come to light
she just she just snagged four high-end
homes
for 3.2 million bucks in the u.s alone
who knows what the other what other
purchases she's made
now you're going to hear that patrice
keller she made her own money in some
places she made a little bit of money
selling a blm book okay that was her
kind of her own money where did the rest
of this money come from i don't really
know
now you're going to hear people say this
is not fair and this is awful and maybe
patrice colors is going to
going to be booted from blm yeah maybe
maybe not something tells me though that
she just wields political power
in a very clever way and she'll be fine
it's not a big shock oh my gosh you know
wow
she made a lot of money of course she
did big politics makes big money that's
the way it goes
big money invites big politics
and you're going to hear some
conservatives say oh well now this now
this communist
is is perfectly fine with capitalism now
that she's rich
yeah it was always sort of the same
thing was always a power grab what the
left is doing is not coherent
ideologically or otherwise and so yeah
it's a big power grab but guess what
they grab the power
they have the power this broad left-wing
movement from the
radical explicit communists
like patrice cullers all the way to
the more mainstream types in the elected
office who support them
they now have the power of the parallel
government of the liberal establishment
they have more power than ron desantis
in florida they have more power
than elected republicans maybe we should
start amassing and wielding political
power
for the good not for the not for the bad
like they do for the good
ourselves if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you